it's it's God damn dude that's it's so I
mean all there's so much bad [__] going
on but at the same time too it's also
these evil people at top as well there's
it's these 1centers of 1 percenters at
the top that allow this pharmacology
it's like just to allow I mean they
allowed like they I mean it's not the
it's not the scientist fault that they
created the the Plan B pill and they
created the you know the U what's it
called the birth control pill it's these
evil agencies within either the
government or within like you know these
whatever these one world order people
that pushed out this [__] during the'
60s and the ' 50s and the 70s and stuff
to be out there everywhere plan and plan
B used to you know what plan B really
orig what it was it was to control the
black population so